foreign
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today I get to be told by my guests that
my questions are pretty intense which is
funny because the guest today is Rich
Roll
um I went on rituals show when I was
promoting my book called pretty intense
back in the beginning of 2018 and I did
three shows I did Rich's show Lewis
Howes and Joe Rogan and after I did
those shows I mean I didn't even know
what podcasts were barely at that point
I was like I'm gonna sit down for how
long with somebody I got to tell him how
grateful I was for that experience
because it's by doing those podcasts
that I fell in love with them and I was
like that's a really fun format I love
going deep like I have energy for that
the seven or 15 minute interviews are
like you're gonna ask me the same thing
everyone always asks me and it's not
going to be that interesting in my mind
um okay ritual is he's an ultra
endurance athlete maybe how you've heard
of him he's written many books um
including an autobiography about his
story cookbooks as well as now he has
books out called voicing change volume 2
is out and they are highlighting through
photography beautiful photography as
well as little synopsis of stories from
his guests he's also a public speaker
and of course a podcaster yeah what do
two podcasters talk about you know we
talked about life we talked about like
how it goes how he was able to get to
where he's at transformation was a big
Topic at the beginning and he loves to
talk to people about it but I'm like
you're a transformation guy so we got to
got to hear the stories about what
that's like for him so that maybe he can
help others understand you know that
process and then we just Rift on life
you know what what what's gonna solve
The World's problems I hope you love the
show and you hit subscribe and the
battle for notifications and please
leave your comments below about maybe
your thoughts as to how we could change
the world for the better where were we
with the podcast before the podcast
again talking about how awesome podcasts
work
yeah how enriching your experience has
been how many amazing people you get to
meet the how the research nourishes you
it's all good I think of it as like
almost a a phenomenal scam to Hoodwink
amazing people and hijack them and make
them spend time with you and as a result
you get nourished you get to share that
with the audience and and then a lot of
these people as I'm sure you've had this
experience like become your friends or
they become you know people in your life
which is such a cool thing there's just
something magical that happens when you
like Escape out of the old Paradigm of
the seven minute interview and or
15-minute interview and you enter this
like hour hour and a half or whatever it
ends up being podcast or there's like a
real special connection yeah well I
think if you're gonna talk to somebody
for an extended period of time uh
hopefully you will get to see you'll get
a glimpse of who that real person is and
if you can establish
trust and a sense of comfort you know
I'm talking as a host and I'm sure
you've experienced this as well when you
can kind of establish that emotional
connectivity and make them feel safe
then they're more likely to
be more vulnerable and I think everybody
listen people like to talk about
themselves too and if you can be truly
interested in that person
you you are in a position to you know
discover a little bit of magic I think
do you have any like techniques do you
have any certain things that you do that
yeah so you do the laugh is a yes
I mean not not techniques I mean for me
it's it's always an intuitive uh
Adventure but I have learned that
um
that I have to be naturally curious in
the person that I'm sitting across from
um if I'm not feeling it within myself
then the experience is probably going to
be flat for The Listener or the viewer
even if that person is amazing like I'm
not the right host
to have that conversation with that
person so
um you know booking the guests is
something that I still do uh you know I
can't imagine having anyone else book it
because it's my own you know curiosity I
think that drives the whole thing and I
think research is really important there
are certain hosts who can just you know
show up without any preparation and and
create something amazing out of that I'm
not one of those people you know I have
to do a lot of homework uh but then I
have to like let go of that homework and
try to just show up and be as present as
possible and allow the experience to be
what it wants to be rather than like
holding on tight like I need to make
sure that we hit these topics like I try
to you know it's a dance of like okay
there's a certain direction I want to go
but I also you know have to sit back and
and let it be what it wants to be and I
think within that
is the importance of of listening you
know instead of being caught up in your
head about oh my God what's my next
question going to be or you know I just
had a brain fart and I can't remember
what I wanted to talk about and just you
know being present I think allows you to
kind of flow with you know wherever the
guest wants to go how much of the time
would you say your interviews end up
following uh any kind of intended flow
or question like what percentage of the
things that you think you're gonna hit
on do you hit on uh yeah I think it
depends on the type of guess like if I'm
having a scientist for example on then
it's going to be much more outline
driven like there are certain things I
want to make sure to cover to make it as
impactful for the audience as possible
as opposed to somebody who just has an
amazing story that's going to be a
different type of approach but on
average I'd say you know maybe in the 70
to 80 percent range of what I want to
cover I think it's important to leave
the audience not exhausted but want
wanting more so you know rather than
like this is a lecture and we have to
cover all of these things and at the end
of that experience everyone is exhausted
like that's not the experience I'm
trying to cultivate like I want them I
think there's you know like there's
something about
um
covering most of it and then if that
person is left from The Experience like
excited about it then they're going to
go on their own adventure to dig deeper
and learn more about that subject matter
or or that person
um and I think also you can run into the
problem of preparing too much where you
know the answer to every question so
yeah I have to kind of hold back on the
prep too so you have the opportunity of
being surprised like oh my God I didn't
know that tell me more about that
because if you already know then you
know you're gonna your reaction is gonna
be flatter than it would be if it was a
more organic experience so it is that
tension between you know being prepared
but also being uh you know not so
schooled up that uh you can kind of be
surprised and put yourself in the
position of the audience what do you
think makes a good guess I think this is
kind of an interesting question because
uh you know sometimes there's
unexpectedly really good guests so what
for you you what for you makes that
really good good guess most important is
is that the guest wants to be there
they're not there because a publicist
told them they needed to do it like
they're they're they're genuinely
excited like oh my God I get to sit down
and talk to Danica like how cool is that
so they're ready and good to go I think
that's important
um I think you know people who have a
grasp of of how to tell a good story is
important not everybody knows how to do
that it's a skill and a talent in its
own right or somebody who really has
command over their field of expertise
and not only you know is an expert in
their field but has the communication
skills to convey that information in a
way that isn't too complicated for the
audience but also isn't speaking down to
the audience I think that's another you
know very specific skill set uh that
that not everybody has and listen when
you do many many of these like I've done
over or 700 at this point like not
everyone is going to crush it so then
the responsibility rests on your
shoulders as the host to you know create
the best experience with a guest who's
not media trained or doesn't understand
you know the nuances of how to
communicate effectively on a podcast and
to you know bring out the best of of you
know that that that person where do you
think vulnerability fits in with that
and maybe actually Define vulnerability
I mean vulnerability is the the courage
to express something that is intimate to
you that isn't necessarily public
knowledge that uh uh that that reveals
uh a more shrouded truth about that
person it doesn't have to be an
embarrassing story it just has to be
something that is emotionally real and I
think vulnerability is hugely important
you know I've learned to be vulnerable
and it's kind of a scary thing to talk
about stuff that maybe you'd rather not
be part of the public discourse but I
think in sharing you know my own
vulnerability publicly it gives other
people the courage to think more deeply
about their own experiences and I think
it creates a connection with the guest
and also with the audience like if I'm
in a podcast conversation where
somebody's sharing a story and I want to
go a little bit deeper I can't expect
them to have the courage to to take that
extra step and go someplace maybe
they've never gone before if I'm not
willing to do it myself so I always try
to lead with vulnerability which then
creates a safer place where the the
trust level in increases and it's not
appropriate for all conversations you
know again like if I have a medical
doctor and I'm trying to learn about
something very specific maybe
vulnerability isn't you know really part
of that equation but you know if
somebody has endured an extraordinary
hardship and you know had struggle in
their life and come out the other side
you know that's a story where
vulnerability is super important and
again it goes back to you know trust and
safety like always trying to create like
a really
um
comfortable space where you know the
microphones and the cameras kind of
vanish into the background and it's just
you know two people who are locked in on
each other and for that reason like
trying to cultivate that emotional
connection is super important so leading
with vulnerability is one is one way
that I do that but
you know really listening to somebody
like somebody knows when they're being
seen and when they're being listened to
and if I can figure out a way to uh you
know know enough about that person where
it's like oh let's talk about this thing
because we can really connect over that
and then we're like locked in with each
other then I think we're in a better
position for that person to maybe reveal
something about themselves that they
haven't before or that is you know
sensitive
um
so you know I think that's another kind
of like little dance and I I'm not
sharing that as a way to manipulate the
person that really doesn't seem like you
don't get the best out of what they have
to say yeah yeah this is like kind of a
new phase in in society with having so
much information now available in this
sort of expansive platform Arena of
podcasts
um and I mean there's been somewhat long
format in the past of course but they're
going to be like you know uh not much
more few and far between so what do you
think the ripple effect of
this new delivery of information and
vulnerability and sharing and stories
and personality what do you think that
that that ripple effect is in society
I think it's a net positive you know I
think we're very much in the Adolescent
phase of of the internet and trying to
get our footing with how to manage such
a powerful distribution system that
connects Us in in such a profound way
but also you know we've seen how it can
be uh you know weaponized or used for
not so positive purposes and I think
younger Generations are much savvier
than older people about trying to
separate truth or reality from fiction
or manipulation but on the net I would
say that the podcasting
um world
has had an incredible effect on raising
awareness and providing people with not
just tools and information but stories
to help guide how we think about what it
means to be human you know what it is
that we value where we want to invest
our time and our Focus like not a day
goes by that I don't reflect on what it
would have been like when I was a young
person trying to figure out what I
wanted to do with my life and I could
and I could just dial up a podcast of
somebody who is excelling in a
particular field and listen to them tell
the story about how they you know got to
that place like I just think it's an
incredible resource for anybody we're
all trying to level up on some level
we're all trying to grow we're all you
know maybe less than satisfied with
where we're at in life and trying to
figure out how to get to that place
where we can be more fulfilled or more
Purpose Driven or or happier in our
career choices or our relationship ships
and there's just you know almost an
infinite amount of content out there for
free that is yeah on tap with just a few
clicks that can really help a lot of
people and I I just I can't think of
anything more gratifying for me
personally to spend my time doing than
to contribute to that
well you talked about you know sharing
and and
um it makes me think about how much
restriction and
um
Shadow Banning people and you know this
is an opportunity to
have an opinion or say something it's
not possible that whatever I say or
whatever you say every single time
everybody will agree with you know or
even at any point in time they'll always
be disagreements but were you affected
in the last couple of years with just
how overwhelming the control of
um messaging has been uh was I affected
I mean I was affected just like
everybody else trying to figure out you
know what's true and what's not and
um you know who are the authorities that
I should be listening to and who are The
Authority the authorities that shouldn't
be trusted and you know what is the
relationship between mainstream media
and alternative media it was very
disorienting you know I'm somebody who's
you know pretty online especially for
somebody who's my age and uh and it was
you know confusing for the most
conscientious person trying to make good
choices about their information diet was
I affected personally in terms of of the
podcast like you know I don't I don't
know I don't I mean I don't think so I'm
not out I'm not somebody who's out
courting controversy in that regard
um but I am trying to have important
meaningful conversations about things
that affect everybody and you know I
think
the the one of the challenges that that
you know I spend a lot of time thinking
about is
is
the relationship between the quality of
content that we choose to put out there
versus
um what you know the algorithm favors or
becoming uh you know a prisoner of
audience capture like I know that if I
were to host person X Y or Z that I
could create you know a title and a
thumbnail for that episode that would
attract a lot of attention and probably
increase subscriber growth and create a
mini media cycle for being controversial
but I'm not really interested in doing
that like I'm trying to create Timeless
conversations that that exist kind of
outside
um you know what's popular today and I
think that takes a little bit of
maturity and also you know may have
sacrificed the growth and the the reach
of what I'm doing but I can sleep at
night knowing that you know I am sort of
adhering to my personal values yeah so I
don't know if that answers your question
it does it does and I agree I love that
I think that um just knowing who you are
is the most I think an important part to
the podcast actually that's an
interesting question how has it evolved
because you know I feel like even for
myself like the beginning versus now I'm
like wow okay there's like a form to it
there's like a certain sort of pattern
of questions I ask a lot of people
there's a pattern of how I interview
people there's there's a feel to it so
they're definitely listening to the
guest but it's um there's a part of
course that always gets Guided by me so
there's sort of an identity there and
have has has that uh morphed for you or
did you discover it was there ever an
arrival of like after 200 episodes or 50
episodes or something like that you go
God this is what it's this is my this is
what my show's about
um that's a great question I think
uh the show has told me what it is and
what it wants to be through the doing of
it uh I feel like it still adheres quite
closely at Hues very tightly to what uh
what it's always been which is
interesting conversations with people
that inspire me in different ways and
you know over 700 episodes I think
themes emerge like obviously I have an
interest in Endurance Sports and you
know ultra distance Trail Runners and
stuff like that like those people tend
to you know recur as guests on the show
and that's you know something that I'm
personally interested in but also is a
very small subculture like I understand
when I have these people on those are
not going to be massive episodes but I
think that there's a lot of wisdom to be
mined from a lot of those individuals
but I think the overarching you know
theme if there was one to be articulated
would be transformation like how do we
you know level up every single day how
can we change our lives from where we
are today and and you know grow into
this other place and exploring that uh
you know opens up a pretty wide aperture
to you know looking at you know sort of
examples of people who have done that in
various interesting ways and then you
know the Mind Body Spirit approach to
accomplishing that which allows me to
talk to you know all kinds of people
from you know uh you know practitioners
of various you know spiritual you know
philosophies or academics again medical
doctors athletes entrepreneurs how do we
do this in business
Etc so I've always cast a pretty wide
net and again the the rule is you know
oh is this person somebody who would be
compelling and that I'm naturally
interested in speaking to and and you
know has some wisdom to impart to the
audience that would be helpful and
practical to you know incorporate into
their lives perfect word because one of
the things that I notice about you or my
observation of you is that you've had
many Transformations I mean that's
literally in my notes of
diving deeper into you and I was like
you've just gone through so many
Transformations you really I feel like
you really have through different phases
of your life everything from uh how you
grew up and not you know claiming to be
an entrepreneur to
um being uh having addiction to being an
endurance athlete to having a successful
podcast now books and it's like
you know uh veganism I mean there's just
so many different I feel like
Transformations so while you ask
everyone your main curiosity is
transformation in my opinion you are
like top of the list for people that
have had so many magnificent
Transformations and have so many stories
so it's definitely your turn to tell the
story of of how you were able to do that
and what I mean I guess I'm really
curious about what what allows you to be
able to move from one phase to another
phase and was it effort or is that
something that actually comes natural
not not everything's easy but that is
seemingly from an observational
standpoint very much part of your life
yeah well I I appreciate that
observation Danica I mean I I don't I'm
not sure exactly how to dive into this I
I would say that the changes and the
Transformations that I've endured in my
life are generally uh catalyzed by some
kind of pain point you know where where
the pain of my current uh situation
exceeded the fear of doing something
different and that has typically been my
motivator and I've gone Kicking and
Screaming into all of these
Transformations none of it was graceful
linear or or overnight it's you know
when you kind of look at it in the rear
view mirror me now being an older person
it all kind of looks like it unfolded
very naturally and gracefully but you
know the lived experience of that was
very different but you know as a result
of of having to change or being
compelled to change because of pain has
taught me a few things about the nature
of change itself and you know that began
with my struggle with alcoholism and
ultimately getting sober and you know
learning tools for a different way of
living which you know I think opened me
up to the possibility a that you know I
could change and if I could could change
other people could change and as a
result of my participation in the
recovery Community being witness being
witness to so many people changing their
lives in miraculous ways and then
understanding that you know change isn't
a static thing like we have to continue
to grow and iterate like there is no
stasis there's no sitting on our Laurels
and you know yes I have you know
weathered that experience and overcome
it but what are the other areas of my
life that remain hidden or that I don't
want to look at that you know require
redress and ultimately some level of
transformation and I've kind of you know
repeated that time and time again like
from addiction issues to transferring
addiction issues onto workaholism and my
relationship with food and my
relationship with my physical self like
all of those have gone undergone you
know massive Transformations over the
years but this process still continues
like now I'm a parent and I have teens
that have their own issues and you know
there's many times where I feel at a
complete loss as a parent as to how to
you know help these younger people or
parent them or guide them in the best
way possible and that provides an
opportunity for me to have people on the
podcast tell me how to do this you're
the expert
Etc so
you know as they say in the parlance of
recovery the road gets narrower and you
know the the kind of more you grow the
less tolerant you are of other aspects
of how you behave uh that you know
ultimately you can't sleep at night
until you look at them and you know so
that's sort of been the approach to all
of it but it's not like I wake up in the
morning and I'm like what am I going to
change today I'm so excited like I hold
on tightly to you know my my you know
errant Behavior patterns of which there
are still many
because it's easier I mean like human
nature is to repeat patterns I think
that's like we're programmed to repeat
the patterns that are instilled into us
and so I think maybe the way to uh get
more focused and help people is
explaining the process of a
transformation first of which is that
you don't want it right like because the
transformation is going to be hard like
I would say like lessons are not meant
to be easy you know their their lessons
are hard and so maybe first what are the
signs like as you've been through so
many different phases of this have you
been able to
become more uh aware and conscious of
getting to a certain point where you're
like these things start happening when I
know that I need to grow yeah I mean
that's a huge subject matter I mean I
guess I would begin by
saying that you know we all do things
that we know are not moving Our Lives
forward like we know when we're spending
too much time scrolling on our phone
that we probably would be happier and
more productive if we were doing
something else and yet we keep doing it
right that would be a you know a very
relatable example of that so the first
step in making change is is is is is
simply awareness like okay this is a
problem
um
and you know kind of snapping out of the
denial that like it's fine you know I
could keep doing this and really getting
honest with yourself to say I know that
I would be a happier more productive
person if I could shed this particular
thing that is holding me back so you
know self-awareness key self-honesty
super important and then I think the
first step
of of of of really approaching that
change is asking for help and not trying
to do it yourself like regardless of
what the nature of the problem is like
because I think once you confide in
another human being that you have a
problem and that you would like help
suddenly no longer it's this private
thing that's living inside of you you
have publicly announced it or
semi-publicly announced it and I think
that's huge because now it's out there
and there's sort of a release or a
catharsis with just admitting it like
that's why you know you when you go into
an AAA meaning you raise your hand and
you say you know my name's rich and I'm
an alcoholic like you are making a
public Declaration of a problem that
requires a redress so I think that's
huge
and then
you know with the trusted people with
whom you've confided this problem
I think the key the absolute key beyond
anything else in making a change is
willingness the willingness to do
something different and the willingness
to not only ask for help but to accept
help so when that trusted Confidant says
well why don't you do this instead of
retorting with all the reasons why
that's a bad idea and you know how to
solve it just saying okay and then doing
it and getting into action even if those
actions are tiny like uh maybe I'll
reduce my phone consumption you know 20
percent or whatever they don't have to
be massive gigantic gestures like I'm
gonna throw my phone in the ocean and
never use a cell phone again like those
tend to be you know losing propositions
over the Long Haul and what you're
really trying to do is establish a new
behavioral pattern that will withstand
the test of time and be sustainable so
the sustainable change happens with tiny
iterations that you know little
behavioral tweaks that you master and
become kind of rote in your experience
over time and the big changes that you
seek really are a function of tiny
little things that you do repeatedly
consistently over extended periods of
time that's how you move the needle on
on anything frankly yeah I think I think
that's what James Clear says in atomic
habits it's like you think that it's
like all of a sudden one thing happens
and then oh there it is but it's
actually been all of the little things
that you've done over and over and over
again so many times and then all of a
sudden things do change but you but it
can look like it it wasn't that but it
does take that commitment to it so
what's the
what's the shittiest part
like I think this is where for me
transformation and growth and like I
feel like it's important for people to
just know that there is a really really
shitty part like there's a there's a
there's whether it's emotionally or in
your immediate reality with people where
you live your job whatever like there
can be there there usually is in my
experience anyway the bigger the
transformation usually it comes with a
package that is like wow this is a lot
right now this is a very overwhelming
amount of stuff but I think that that
talking about the what I would call it
like the Alchemy or the the burning down
of something so something else can be
born and and grow new from it is
important for people to understand has
that been your experience too well yeah
you can't you can't be a phoenix unless
you burn first right you gotta right in
the Flames that's what this is kind of
emerge with a greater wisdom right but I
think the thing is Danica I mean frankly
I think it all sucks it's terrible like
there's nothing like sexy or romantic
about like trying to make a change it's
a very difficult uncomfortable you know
inelegant thing and I you know to the
extent that the internet paints it as
you know something that's that's easy or
that can be accomplished you know
without discomfort I think is a
disservice to people I think it is
important to tell people like yeah it
[ __ ] sucks it's really hard like the
reason it's hard is because whatever
you're doing whether it's gambling or
you keep getting into the you know the
same bad relationship or you know you
drink too much or whatever you know the
change is that you're trying to make
it's important to understand that that
behavior exists for a reason and the
reason is it's serving a purpose like
it's either taking you out of the the
the discomfort of the moment or it's a
reflection of you know know a childhood
trauma or it's a behavioral pattern that
got cemented very early in life that
makes you feel secure and in control
whatever the nature of it the truth
remains that you're doing it for a
reason and that reason is because it is
serving you it may be creating chaos in
your life as well but it is comforting
you in a certain way and when you ask
that person look you got to stop doing
that or the person decides like I can't
do this anymore you're asking them to
break up with with a with a good friend
right they're having to they have to
like part ways with this thing that has
been a comfort blanket for them for a
very long and so the early days of of
you know navigating letting go of that
is almost a morning and it's super
painful and it's really uncomfortable
and there will be many moments where you
know you're going to want to go back to
it or the discomfort of having to really
confront the challenging emotions that
start coming up when you don't have that
comfort blanket can be completely
overwhelming and it's why mastering a
change or overcoming an addiction can be
so difficult and you know I use I don't
use the word Addiction cavalierly like I
think addiction really lives on a
spectrum so on the far end of that
Spectrum you have you know the hardcore
alcoholic or the heroin addict Etc but
you know I think that we all live
somewhere along this spectrum because
we're all engaging in behaviors that we
know are not a reflection of our higher
self and yet we can't seem to stop doing
them and you know and and they're not
making our lives better they're making
our lives worse and that's the classic
definition of of addiction so you know
looking Inward and being honest with
yourself about what those behaviors are
and summoning the courage to redress
them is a difficult thing and then
making that change yeah it's really
difficult and you're going to be
uncomfortable for quite a while before
your neurochemistry resets or you find
some other healthier activity or Pursuit
that can you know provide you with you
know whatever the errant Behavior you
know was doing for you and that's why
most people in you know a classic
addiction sense either
relapse or people just can't you know
Master a healthier Behavior pattern and
kind of retreat back to what what what
they know what's familiar and what's
comfortable as you were talking I was
going to ask you if
re-patterning or going through a
transformation learning something new
doing something new dropping a habit
felt to you
um as though it's it's an addiction and
you totally answered it it's I try and
think about that when things are really
hard it's like I'm from a neurochemistry
standpoint my brain gets this dopamine
sort of hit every time I repeat a
pattern and it doesn't have to be a good
one and I I try and convince myself that
like it's it's hard because I'm addicted
to it so then the question becomes like
are you willing to do something about
that and if the answer is no like I kind
of like it and I'm gonna stick with it
like no judgment you know like okay
maybe you need to keep doing it until
things get crazier and then you're then
you're ready to look at it because you
still go to AAA a lot as far as I
understand and what is that kind of
taught you because this as we're talking
about it can holistically be overlaid to
everything like addiction is just like
you said a scale so so what are the what
are the tools that help you with this
spectrum
yeah it's a little tricky because
there's a tradition in Alcoholics
Anonymous that you know we're not
supposed to share at the level of press
radio and film so I can only speak
generally about about you know kind of
the recovery modality but it has been
absolutely transformative in my life the
12 Steps saved my life they continue to
save my life and you know to this day my
number one priority is to stay sober and
help another alcoholic achieve sobriety
and the minute I start to lose sight of
that or I de-prioritize that in my life
is the minute that things in my life
start to go a little bit sideways and
I've learned that the hard way as
somebody who's been sober for a very
long time but you know kind of the
principles of this program I think are
applicable to anyone and everyone
because they're really tools for living
they're about you know being being
honest with yourself about your behavior
you know taking into inventory of that
behavior and identifying where your
Character defects or your behavior
contributed to how a situation went
sideways it's about taking
accountability and responsibility for
that
and then you know amending those
situations not just apologizing but
literally trying to correct uh
situations that have gone sideways as a
result of your behavior and so now it's
very rare that I have the impulse or the
craving to drink or or use a drug it's
really about emotional sobriety because
without drugs and alcohol I need
something else to self-regulate and
modulate my emotions and if I'm not
practicing these principles and taking
advantage of these tools then
you know it's like squeezing a a water
balloon like something's always like
popping up you know like because my
inner addict is always searching for
that thing that can take me out of the
moment and you know soothe me or give me
that dopamine release and it requires
like constant vigilance and sometimes
I'm good at it and often I'm bad at it
uh and then you know beyond that a
really core fundamental principle of
this program is to really be of service
to other people like that piece of like
helping another alcoholic to achieve
sobriety really it's about service so
it's taking what you've what you've
learned and you know trying to help
other people who are in the situation
that you were in once before and I try
to practice these principles and you
know this is a big thing like practice
these and everything that you do and
certainly in the construct of the
podcast which yes it's a for-profit
Enterprise and this is how I make a
living but you know fundamentally it's
still enact service so I always try to
approach the conversations and and what
transpires there from a perspective of
of giving to the audience something
nourishing that can be helpful to them
is that the purpose of the podcast would
you say I understand this that it's you
monetize it but what would you do if you
didn't make money like if any of the
facets of it what what part of it would
stay if you didn't get get paid well I
mean I did do I've been doing it for 10
years now and I think we didn't make any
money for the first four or five years
so I did it for many years without
making any money and actually never
thought that it would make money like
podcasting was very different back in
2012 and 2013 so it's like it's almost
like a accidental happenstance that now
it's become this thing that that
generates a fair amount of Revenue would
I still do it if it didn't make any
money yeah I probably would uh it
probably wouldn't I would probably but I
would have to be doing a lot of other
things in my life at the same time
whereas now this can really you know
kind of monopolize as most of my focus
the books that you have this voicing
change you have
um uh vegan are you still a vegan okay
so you have like there was a cheese book
I remember you gave me a cheese book
when I came to your house and did the
interview and
um you have an ultra marathon or Ultra
athlete uh book you and then but these
voicing change books they they feel like
coffee table books is that the intended
nature of them to be inspirational kind
of like coffee table books yeah so in
2012 I wrote A Memoir Finding Ultra that
came out and has done great still sells
and then my wife and I did a couple
cookbooks and then she wrote this book
called uh this cheese is nuts which is
how to make plant-based cheese and now
she has a plant-based cheese company
called shreemu which if you don't have
it I would love to send you some oh cool
and then the voicing change books yeah
I'll get your address and I'll make sure
you get some it's amazing it's gonna
blow your mind but anyway uh so the
voicing change book are we've done two
volumes we're working on a third right
now and they are really as you mentioned
like a coffee table version of the
podcast it's beautiful photography each
book has about 50 past guests who are
featured and we kind of excerpt the best
of that conversation and transcribe it
with an introduction that I make and we
have some essays from some of the past
guests so for people who might have read
uh Tim ferriss's book tools of Titans
it's sort of a coffee table version of
that that is intended not for a giant
audience like we self-published these
which was its own kind of
entrepreneurial experience of learning
how to create a book in-house they're
really for the fans of the podcast and
also for potential sponsors or people
that I want to do business with we can
send it to them and it's an example of
you know how we're trying to craft
content at the highest level of
production value like everything that
we're doing is you know from my mind
like
the intention is always to deliver at
the highest level that we possibly can
and sort of set the standard for the
whole podcasting business about like how
to do this well
yeah they're really really cool I love
that because podcasts are obviously so
much to digest they're
you know as we talked about they can be
hours long and so to be able to create
um create a moment create an idea from
that
um is so so cool and so powerful I get
asked this all the time who have your
favorite guests been who creates the
most
um like concise clear points that are
really impactful what are some of your
best communicators because there's a lot
of great guests and when people ask me
I'm like I'm literally just got asked
today by my sister's husband and I'm
like there's barely any that I don't
like so it's hard for me to say well
this is the best it's really about who
surprises me or um who is really able to
um be very concise and clear with their
words and help it land because not
everyone is incredible at getting a
concept across into a tangible way so
who who who do you love and who makes
the book in that way
yeah I mean that's a as you know it's
always a difficult question to answer
like I I don't want to have to choose
amongst my babies and everybody that I
invite onto the podcast is somebody who
I'm already in love with and I'm excited
to communicate with you know there are
of course you know a couple favorites
and and and the favorites again it
depends on what kind of category you're
interested in like on the subject of of
communication skills
um I think you know Andrew huberman is
somebody who stands out and excels uh
Stanford uh Medical School Professor
neuroscientist who started his podcast
huberman lab which is now like one of
the most popular podcasts and I think
what is so
the reason why he's become so successful
and that was like the YouTube version of
the podcast that we did which came out
like before he even started his podcast
I think has 12 million views now which
blows my mind because it's basically a
two-hour Neuroscience lecture that 12
million people would tune into that it's
like why do why does why did 12 million
people decide to watch this video and
trying to answer that question I think
it's it's it's because
he's taking challenging
um
scientific ideas that have high
applicability in our lives and
communicating incredibly complex ideas
in a way as I said at the outset that
challenges the audience but not too much
and never panders to them like he's like
I know that you can understand me if
you're paying close attention and he has
such Precision with his language like he
not only is a master of his of his
specialty he has this incredible talent
and facility for language
precise language in conveying these
ideas that I think distinguishes him
from a lot of other people like most
scientists are not communicators they're
in Labs doing work it's not their skill
set so it's pretty rare that I think you
can find somebody who is adept in that
way and he certainly is beyond that you
know my favorite guests are generally
ones that that that have undergone some
kind of massive transformation
and you know kind of at the top of that
Heap I would put John McAvoy I just did
my second podcast with him recently
which came out but the first one that I
did with him which was about four or
five years ago
he just blew my mind with the most
insane story of transformation I had
ever heard this is a guy who grew up in
a South London crime family and was
reared from a very very early age to be
an armed robber almost in a in a kind of
Goodfellas sense the uncles and the you
know cousins and all of that who who
were very successful as as career
criminals kind of grooming him at a very
young age to do the same which he
fulfilled that role and became one of
Great Britain's most notorious criminals
on the lamb Etc and ultimately it's a
long story but ultimately
um gapos did was serving a double life
sentence and while in prison discovered
uh
uh a facility for Endurance by Dent of
experimenting with an indoor rowing
machine in the gym which to make a long
story short he ends up setting in a very
short period of time British and World
indoor records on that indoor rowing
machine
and becomes this incredible athlete
while incarcerated ultimately gets a
chance at parole tells the parole
officer that if he is released that he's
going to pursue a career as a
professional athlete they laughed at him
ultimately they parole him he goes out
into the world tries to become a
professional rower realizes that because
he didn't have the experience as a young
person in the boat like he couldn't
quite get the feel even though he had
this incredible engine and then pursues
Iron Man Triathlon and becomes Nikes
only uh only sponsored professional Iron
Man triathlete and then goes on to the
career of of prison reform advocacy
testifying at 10 Downing Street and has
just become this extraordinary
citizen intent on you know changing the
way that we incarcerate people
building fitness programs into the
prison system and the way he tells his
story is so compelling and so cinematic
that it just it's it's mind-blowing and
it it shows people it demonstrates
that no matter how far down you have
gone that there is always hope and the
way in which he refused to relinquish
agency over his life or to lose hope in
a possible future for himself is
incredibly palpable so you know I've got
a couple other guests who have similar
stories like that but I think those are
among you know my favorite because
they're so hopeful and I think people
learn through story and a story well
well told is going to rent
space in your Consciousness in the way
that you know just a conveyance of
information isn't and so I have massive
respect for you know not only people who
have endured such tremendous obstacles
but have the ability to tell that story
in a way that you know can Empower so
many people
what do you think we're here for I could
talk about that story and talk about how
someone's able to
still find a way with all of that how
you tell your story and have found a way
we've all been finding our way what is
this reality all about like what are we
what do you think we're here for
you're coming you're coming in hot with
the easy questions right
the podcast is called pretty intense
right it's after my book
it was the book and then I really
realized that like it's a pretty good
description of me like
I guess you know it's uh I I love the
big questions it's also you know
sometimes when you get really specific
there's sort of like only this one
little area to go but when I you get a
little bit more broad whatever comes to
mind I want to hear because you're
uniquely different than me
hmm yeah well that would this qualifies
as a pretty intense question I I guess I
would say
you know what do we hear what what are
we here for what are we here to do
I mean I think we're here we're here to
have experiences grow from those
experiences and then figure out how to
contribute to a better world
by virtue of what we've learned as a
result of those experiences and the
growth that we've encountered as a
result of them yeah I mean growing is
fundamental to me as well
um what do you think do you think that
it's easier or harder in the world right
now like there just seems to be a I mean
the world in the last couple of years
has just been so interesting and
different and at times it feels like
timelines are so fast and I don't know
how spiritual you get or anything but it
just um it's it seems like a different
reality we continue to evolve into and
so
um you know
do you think it's easier or harder than
ever do you think there is more good
than ever or more bad than ever I think
it's a I think it's a little bit of both
I I would I would say that things are
pretty intense right now for everybody
right it is very intense out there
Everything feels intense
um Everything feels heavy uh and it's
it's an interesting time because we have
access free access to so many tools
to help us become better happier more
fulfilled Etc but we also have a culture
that
um
I think in certain ways coddles us and
tells us that the recipe for happiness
is comfort and luxury and material
accumulation and so it's never been
easier to be kind of sedentary right and
with the sedentary nature of our lives
and the easy access through Postmates
and delivery you know
services to have our food you know sent
directly to us like we don't have to do
very much right it's kind of the lap of
luxury and we want it yeah and we've and
we've deluded ourselves into thinking
this will make us happy but I think this
is moving us further and further apart
from happiness because happiness is a
function of of
feeling alive and in order to feel alive
we have to endure ourselves to putting
ourselves in in in challenging
circumstances to get out of our comfort
zone and try new things and you know our
culture doesn't necessarily drive us in
that direction which means we have to
take responsibility for that ourselves
it's insane to me that you know we live
in a nation that is so unbelievably
prosperous and yet we've never been more
unhealthy as a society obesity rates
type 2 diabetes heart disease these
conditions which are lifestyle chronic
lifestyle ailments a result of the way
the choices that we make about how we
live and what we eat and how we move our
bodies are unnecessarily debilitating
and killing millions and millions of
people every year meanwhile our rates of
of
depression anxiety all of these mental
disorders are higher than they ever have
been we're medicating people we're
feeding ourselves terrible processed
foods and we're sitting on our couch and
we have an endless stream of choices to
make about entertainment to distract us
from our reality or whatever it is that
you know we're uncomfortable with in our
lives and so we're in this mild
medicated State at all times whenever
we're bored we can just pick this thing
up and and scroll through it and so I
think we're detached and distanced in a
way that we never have been historically
from what makes us human which is
community and analog experiences and
moving our bodies and living
more in sync with the natural rhythms of
the planet all of these you know kind of
historical Primal ways of being that are
built into our DNA and our instinctual
our anathema to the modern way of life
and you know
so it's so it creates it creates this
dissonance I think because like I said
at the outset
we do have access to all the answers
information is not the problem
Behavior change is the problem uh and
trying to figure out how to
merge the information with the behavior
change I I think is really key but it's
confusing for a lot of people right now
people get mixed messages about about
how to live and again you know it
requires because a lot of these
um modalities of modern living are
highly addictive like right you know
whether it's net Netflix or your phone
or processed food or the comfortable
chair at your house whatever it is like
it's hard to break
those habits because they've been
specifically designed to addict you
frankly so it's almost like not our
fault it's that the whole infrastructure
of our society is driving us towards
these behaviors that are making us
unhealthy and unhappy
design of society design a culture
design a community design a reality that
would be the antidote to all of the
problems that you just
so well laid out
yeah so you're going to ask me to solve
The World's problems Danica that is a
very intense well you've talked more
than 700 people you're really smart
you're very articulate you're very wise
you've been through a lot yourself yeah
I mean I I guess I would say I would say
you know first and foremost like
I'm not going to tell you that I have
the answers to all these problems nor am
I going to tell you that I've mastered
the routine that that uh you know takes
me out of the the Allure and the pull of
the world that we live in you're human I
do do a few things I mean I yeah like
I'm human and I'm on my phone too much
and I get short with my kids from time
to time and you know I like a good you
know Netflix crime show just like
everybody else so I watched Elmer I get
it you know it's yeah okay right
um but I do you know have certain things
that I make sure that I do if not daily
as close to daily as possible and that
is a morning meditation practice a
journaling practice getting out in
nature every single day and I do that
through my endurance training whether
it's you know swimming cycling running
or or hiking or something like that like
I've tried to get Outdoors every single
day I sleep outdoors in a tent I don't
know if you know that
but I actually sleep I sleep outdoors
and have for like the last three or four
years at this point
um that's a whole other story that I can
tell you about but to kind of stay on
point
um you know I try to have rules around
the phone I try to make sure that I
carve out time for friendships no matter
how busy I am and that's something that
I haven't been historically great at and
I'm trying to do more and that kind of
leads into you know the the broader like
what would the society what would the
ideal Society look like for me
uh I think the answer to that is first
appreciating that we're not we're not
going to move backwards technologically
like the the technological innovation
curve is going to continue so accepting
that as a truth and a mutable reality
how can we live more meaningful lives
within that construct I think you know
if we could return to you know not to be
too hippy-dippy about it but if we could
live a more communal existence I think
that would solve a lot of our problems
like it really does take a village to
raise children to feel like you're part
of something bigger than yourself to
have you know Mutual shared
responsibilities for uh you know things
that you know a collective relies upon
like all of those things I think are
what make us human and living uh you
know on a cul-de-sac in a Suburban
neighborhood doesn't serve Us in that
regard and you know as a parent and as
somebody who has parents who are now
elderly and you know my my in you know
my my father-in-law who passed away like
we've all had experiences with with how
we treat our elders which I think is
abominable like it used to be they were
part of the community and they were
respected and these were the wise ones
that we counted upon to share their
experiences like that is not part of our
culture whatsoever we just Warehouse
them once they reach an age in which
they're no longer productive
coming-of-age Customs for young people
where they have to as a collective you
know endure certain uh Rites of Passage
as they become older is also a tradition
that historically has been part of what
it means to be human that's no longer
the case like a vision going around the
camp a vision yeah some something you
know like now we have you know the only
thing we have now is like Boy Scouts
Girl Scouts and bar mitzvahs but you
know the roots of that the antecedent of
those Rites of Passage which have been
you know traditionally much more robust
and challenging and you know I think we
would be better off if every young
person had to enter some form of Public
Service After High School whether that's
military or Peace Corps or you know some
kind of uh collective experience that is
about service because I think you know
we're in a culture where we are we value
individualism and material gain and
status and and you know we're missing
the bigger picture which is how are we
all contributing to a greater whole and
I think that used to be part of the
American experience and now you know as
we've arrived at this splintered
fractured reality that we live in I
don't feel like we have any kind of
shared
principles that allow us to cohere as a
nation and I think a return to what
could really Bond us as a broader
culture would be something that young
people have to all do like some kind of
mandatory service I think would be
extremely beneficial that and definitely
elders and community
I mean that used to be the norm you were
raised with aunts and uncles and
grandparents and yeah listen it's hard
to raise kids and you know even even if
you have a you know two parents in the
house like somebody's got to go do
something it used to be there was tons
of people around everybody's pitching in
to help everybody else and we just live
we're so far divorced from that reality
now and and you know how about just
sitting around the campfire you know at
night telling stories and sharing wisdom
I mean this is where podcasting in a
digital respect has kind of filled that
void I feel like like people
traditionally didn't think that anybody
would be able to listen to a long-form
conversation because we're so accustomed
to the sound bite and you know the
nature of what broadcast television uh
is like and yet podcasting has succeeded
not only succeeded it's become this like
really powerful medium because I think
there is something deep within us that
misses that campfire experience and the
kind of you know vulnerable authentic
natural feel of human connection and I
think podcasting on some level is is
serving that need that has been so long
underserved do you think that maybe
there is is a problem with what is
generally characterized as success when
you ask somebody you know that's truly
been successful at something or older
and has had a lot of experience and you
say what a success they're not going to
answer with I made a lot of money right
but still as you're growing up you still
success and something that drives you
every you know each and every day to
some degree is money and is success in
that way so that you can buy what you
want and do what you want and it's some
sort of measure of success the money is
like a measurement almost
so what if they're do you think that
that is maybe one of the problems and
that maybe success needs to be elevated
in the area of raising really good
children or
um having a really balanced and
harmonious family and you know or just
being joyful and fulfilled I mean
there's so many successful people that
aren't joyful and fulfilled because of
chasing this sort of Illusion of success
that comes in the form of of money and
so I think about when you're talking
about sitting around a campfire and I'm
like what would facilitate that like
what would facilitate the environment
where you're with your within with a
community of your family and your close
friends and I think what takes it apart
and why that doesn't happen is because
people go and they move here for a job
they move here for a job and everybody
gets dispersed because work tends to
take us to these different places so
what is it that's going to give us that
drive to live in a certain place to and
we are driven to succeed driven to be
successful and it seems like maybe there
needs to be a new definition for uh
really really what success is
yeah I mean I would agree with you that
we need to redefine success but the way
that we define success cannot be
extricated from what it means to be
American because America was founded on
this notion of rugged individualism back
to this subject where we value the
individual over the collective and with
that
the priority becomes how are you going
to get yours it's all about like me me
me and what am I accumulating and how
does that measure up status wise against
the Joneses my neighbor my colleagues
Etc and we've deluded ourselves into
believing that happiness is a factor of
how high you can climb that particular
ladder on the Press you know on the on
the precipice to summoning the Apex of
individual success right
and this is completely backwards and
there are plenty of modern Western
cultures that you know have a completely
different view on this and and thus
value a very different definition of
success like if you live in some place
like Copenhagen it's completely
different so there is something uniquely
American about this and I think now
we're we're kind of being hoisted on our
petard for the this sensibility and it's
providing in my opinion an opportunity
to deconstruct this and really look at
it in a culture in which so many people
are unhappy despite you know so many
things being more accessible than they
ever have been like in the history of
mankind like things are are pretty good
we tend to look at how everything is
wrong and terrible and all of that but
you know we're safer Health Care is
better Prosperity is much higher all of
these sort of you know factors uh
statistically indicate that like the
world that we live in now is the best
it's the best time to be alive right so
if it's the best time to be alive like
why are we more unhappy than we used to
be and I think it's because of this
focus on the self at the cost of the
collective and if we can switch or
redefine our notion of success to
contemplate at least on some level how
we're contributing and as opposed to
what it is that we're extracting I think
the that that the kernel of true
happiness you know resides in there and
I I know for myself I'm a selfish person
I'm ambitious I have things that I want
to accomplish I'm competitive I can be
Petty all that stuff but when I can set
that aside and show up for somebody else
even a very small way I walk away from
those experiences
feeling much happier and better about
myself that that experience will fade
and I'll revert back to you know being
my whoever I am so it's a it's a
practice right but I think the more that
we can you know inhabit
uh the experience of of approaching
every interaction uh whether it's
business or personal or whatever with
the mindset of like how am I
contributing to this how can I leave
this situation
[Music]
um with these people being better off
than they were before as opposed to like
where's mine and what am I going to get
out of this to me fundamentally like
that's the beginning of the shift and
you know in my experience and I've had
high highs and low lows and successes
and failures Etc but to me success is
is knowing that you contributed more
than you extracted and success is also a
function of like how much domain you
have over how you spend your time right
so the more control that I have over the
decisions I make about how I spend my
time that's a huge success for me that's
time that I can contribute to friends uh
and to my family into my relationships
and when I do that from a contributory
State of Mind like I just I feel happier
and better and as somebody who's spoken
to centenarians and old people and I'm
sure you have as well like they will all
tell you exactly what you said at the
outset which is you know when they're at
the end of their life reflecting
backwards they never say like I wish I
worked more they say I wish I spent more
time with my kids or I wish I had you
know been a better friend Etc it's all
about like relationships and the extent
to which they contributed to those
relations chips
would you say then that that's your
purpose
to contribute to
be of service what how would you
characterize because they feel a little
different like defining success and then
purpose do you think they go are they
the same or are they different for you I
don't know I don't spend a lot of time
thinking about success but I do think
about purpose yeah you know I don't know
that we all we all have one purpose but
I would say a purpose that I try to
fulfill is is to you know is to be a
conduit of wisdom and to be a servant to
positive change individually and
collectively yeah you are but you're not
getting out of this interview without
answering one last question why do you
sleep in a tent oh no
you wanna I mean you said you would
explain myself intent so you just have
to end with helping out because we might
all start sleeping intense when you tell
us why
sure
uh well it's sort of a sleep hygiene
thing that that began many years ago my
wife and I uh would would always like
have this sort of battle because she
liked the bedroom warm and I like it
cold and neither of us were ever happy
like she's under all the covers and I'm
on top of the cover sweating so it was
always too hot or too cold neither of us
were happy and we have you've been to my
home we have this flat roof beautiful
and there's like a wall that goes up
from one side yeah and one summer
we would do these uh kind of movie
Nights on the roof for all the kids and
my wife and I would would get sleeping
bags and bean bags and we'd lay on the
roof and we would project movies onto
that wall
and one of those evenings I just fell
asleep on the roof under the stars and
woke up the next day having had the best
night of sleep that I could remember and
I was I couldn't I couldn't believe how
deeply I slept like something about the
Cool Desert Air I live in Southern
California
um just agreed with me and I told Julie
uh that day I was like I'm gonna sleep
out on the roof again like that was an
amazing experience and she was like
knock yourself out so I just started
sleeping in a sleeping bag on the roof
of our house but I would wake up covered
in condensation because the Dew and
everything like that in the morning and
I was like well this is great like I'm
having the best sleep of my life and
Julie can set the temperature in the
bedroom however she wants but I love it
cold to me it almost you know like if
it's down in the 40s that's like perfect
oh yeah so I ended up getting a tent and
then I had a tent on a roof for a while
and had many different incarnations of
the tent over the years and then this
past year for my birthday my wife got me
like a proper glamping tent like on a
wooden deck this so I have like a
beautiful kind of room now with a bed in
it so it's not like I'm sleeping on the
ground or anything like that but I do
sleep outdoors and there's something
about the cool evening air
that just I don't know it soothes my
soul and I just have the experience of
sleeping more deeply on a consistent
basis and sleep is elusive for me like
I've struggled with my sleep quality and
this has gone a long way towards you
know providing me with the level of
restfulness that allows me to kind of
you know do all the things in the world
that I want to do and I I've just I
started it way back then and I just I
still love it well well there'll be a
new wave of people out there listening
that struggle with their sleep that are
gonna think
I'm gonna sleep outside tonight and see
how that goes so thank you and listen I
don't live in Vermont you know I live in
Southern California so I realize like
this is wait are the doors open do you
have the tent like are the tent doors
open
I keep them yeah I keep them open I keep
them sleeping
uh well I have I can zip it shut but
there aren't like bugs aren't a big
problem where I am so I like it I like
to keep it as open as possible all right
yeah all right sounds like a solution to
me mm-hmm well thank you very much and
thank you for your contribution and your
service and five years of doing a
podcast and not knowing if you'd ever
make money and look at you now and it
really just goes to show how when you
just surrender to what calls you and
what feels right
um amazing things happen so I'm excited
to see what the next transformation will
be and I'll ask to talk to you
hopefully I don't have to crash and burn
in some kind of crazy way to transform
again we'll see what that looks like but
anyway I I really appreciate the time
today those were like very challenging
questions like I I hope I I hope I
followed through appropriately but you
you had me you had me really thinking
there Danica you were amazing thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today I hope you enjoyed
it if you like what you heard today and
you want to hear more please click on
the Subscribe button